Let's take a look at a generic router
architecture. As a summary of basic router function, a
router receives a packet. It then looks at the
packet header, to determine the packet's destination. It looks
in the forwarding table, to determine the appropriate, output
interface for the packet. It modifies the packet header,
such as decrementing the time to live field and
updating the IP header check sum appropriately. And finally,
it sends the packet to the appropriate output
interface. The basic I/O component of a router architecture
is the line card, which is the interface by
which a router sends and receives data. When a
packet arrives, the line card looks at the header
to determine the destination, and then it looks in
the forwarding table. To determine the output interface. It
then, updates the packet header, and finally, sends the
packet to the appropriate output interface. Now this
drawing shows just a single line card. But in
fact, when the packet is sent to the output
interface, it must traverse the router's interconnection fabric, to
be sent to the appropriate output port. So
in fact, we can zoom out from that depiction
of a single line card, and what we have, is a bunch of line cards, that are all
connected via an interconnection fabric. Each of these
line cards has a lookup table, the capability to
modify headers, and a queue, or buffer, for packets,
as they enter and leave the line card. In
other lessons, we talk about several important questions. Such
as how big queues should be and how lookup
works. In the rest of this lesson, I'll discuss
important decisions in router design. Such as, the placement
of lookup tables on each line card and the design of the interconnection fabric.